votaram todos
hoje vamos falar de portugal o próximo
passo é que vai o nosso caminho pra isso
o programa espaço e não é direito pelo
menos assim não foi pra mim foi com
muito sucesso
muitas curvas e por aí fora
tanto a mensagem estrago também vou
falar de outra coisa são à volta de um
padrão de vida como é que as coisas
estão como é que as peças se encaixam
o que é preciso fazer para que as coisas
aconteçam coisas que a informação que a
pessoa tenha um contato quem quer o
cinema onde na oportunidade o jovem
quando tá bom tá bom
começa dura
temos escola conhecimentos e isso não é
tanto o que aprendemos a aprender e e e
investigar mais e saber mais se for
necessário
aprendemos coisas em conjunto o que faz
eo que não faz como faz o networking
eu não sei fazer isso não interessa mas
eu tinha pensado fazer isso é tão
importante a distância um problema
bastaram três semanas de trabalho aqui o
gás vai fazer isso em cinco minutos
o cinema de lá valores informação uma
série de coisas que valem umas boas
outras mas em tudo nossa mente tem que
saber filtrar tudo os erros às 11
segunda vez já chega não lá nós temos um
objetivo meu e isso é muito importante
josé sertãozinho selecções podem andar
aqui mas a gente tem que chegar na
abaixo os idiomas no mundo global o
mercado global vai crescer
eu só consegui entrar num negócio se for
à escala global pensar grande pensar
grande escala global idiomas a gente tem
que saber falar as línguas tosa são mais
puder a chegar aos países tentar vender
tentar né não
a frança faz uma apresentação em francês
ou não ser boa tem que ser
temos que nos adaptar cliente entrar nos
mercados queremos entrar queremos vender
queremos conseguir poupanças e
investimentos também era como alguém
hoje de manhã quem estava encontrava
josley b a nada e com estas variáveis
aqui à volta da nossa moldura do país
não ajudam
é começar a criar os objetivos que é o
nosso centro certo
uma coisa que nos documentos e é também
muito importante entre nacional e fazer
vários países
o trabalho é mika é idiomas
enfim explorar uma série de coisas que
aprendi como é que se faz noutros países
como é que os ensinam como é que as
coisas são feitas coisas
isso é muito importante o pessoal vive
aqui o que ganhei eu possa aplicar aqui
posso ter a wii
tudo isto além de viver e estudar
trabalhar neste país todos segunda etapa
também é importante são as viagens
cultural e tudo isso ajuda hoje a
portugal conseguindo para todo mundo
foram férias ou viagens tudo encarar a
aventura de seu membro dos 7 aos 22 anos
a mãe no meu quarto a 15 e no mundo viu
aos negócios
a gente tem que ir ao ar no mundo dos
negócios hoje
e isso tudo eu dou é a ganhar agora em
dois momentos um deus é mecânica outro
eletrônica
vamos abrir um negócio vamos fazer aqui
temos um técnico em eletrônica e
mecatrônica
em portugal a empresa passar alguns anos
não era só associado não a gente não
tinha tamanho importante para nós amanhã
só para ter uma idéia o bad a agência
espacial européia são sensivelmente três
mil milhões de euros
é manhã 600 milhões por ano
mas na sua própria agência espacial a
milhões e tem mais não tem problema
nenhum com isso o inglês da inglaterra
é muito importante estar nesta geografia
também conhecimentos
vamos abrindo empresas neste país temos
vindo a fazer uma série de projetos que
alguns são bastante fazendo onde fazemos
pequenos sistemas do chapéu e um
componente estrutural testes fabrico é
só para ter uma idéia até lá em cima da
terra 90 minutos e quarenta e cinco
minutos expostas ao sol ou 150 graus
os outros
minutos atrás da terra dispostas a hora
- chen 151 8 250 graus e passa tudo em
seis minutos e 56 minutos através de 250
grau e material tem que sobreviver
rotações contrações dura 15 anos
não há ninguém vai lá até hoje faço
nós fazemos temos que garantir que vai
funcionar 15 anos e muita dedicação
nós temos que garantir que o vai viver
tudo e vai funcionar os 15 anos lá em
cima do espaço este que é o web do
observatório europeu do sul
acho a imagem mas sim uma imagem a
imagem direita
então faço contrato para calibrar neste
país
o que o imperador vai para cima do
espanhol projeta uma imagem do céu
conhecida uma estrela coisa e nossos
parentes não damos lhe interessam e já
está
já temos é imagem que estamos a
projectar então está calibrado pode
tirar esses elevadores não só deste modo
que nem teria pulado então podemos fazer
nossas observações provaram andando mais
à frente estão mais missões espaciais
este que deve com o now is térmicas é
esta aqui é um projecto ganhamos
paranasa com a nova missão a marte onde
temos um instrumento que vai ser
desenvolvido por nós
é o toque do eterno eterno é um projeto
mundial é onde estuda
a geração de energia nuclear a partir de
fusão e não fiz são aquelas que
eventualmente acontece às drogas e que
usam a temos vários tesouros encontrados
com elas para algumas peças para estes
reatores
nós somos bons
coisas que não podem falhar é esse
projeto é 11 14 ambiente mas em
inglaterra
pense aac manual perto únicas que
desenvolvemos no em almada que comprova
as peças para a linha de montagem olhou
parou toda a fábrica parou é dinheiro
que fazer pra dentro
mas os instrumentos sociais noticia que
a observação terrestre o sentinel outro
sentinel em um satélite espanhol também
fizemos aqui os instrumentos e última
missão que estamos a fazer
o sol só orbital são 550 graus
ganhamos o contrato para fazer as
pecinhas
os guias de onda
a 150 graus dos 11 instrumentos a bordo
do satélite e é feito cá em portugal nós
engenheiros os nossos centros todos os
fábrica e em tudo
foi a partir daqui portugal e as peças
assim vão daqui pro espaço e assim
fazendo toda que o curso etapa traz
forma como vamos preenchendo o padrão
nos ajuda a salvar coisas de portugal
para o espaço
recentemente uma nova temática
tanquinhos aqui não querem que a
eletronic agora já estou há dois meses
no entanto tudo por conta própria até
agora tem 10 anos de história
agora quanto a história de um ano
lançando aqui matemática volta da
química
temos vindo a produzir aerogel que é um
material isolante com dá pra espaço da
paróquia dos gasodutos linhas
criogênicas a absorção de
hidrocarbonetos em um produto altamente
inovador que não há igual na europa a
uma conferência nos estados unidos na
europa
estamos finais e agora aqui uma série de
coisas aqui uma série de buracos neste
país ou da vida que falta tudo vai
acontecer pra frente eu costumo dizer eu
eu não conseguida também porque eu tenho
seu dever e precisava muito disso pode
notar que este buraco não dá para encher
eu tenho tanta coisa que este pastor que
não dá pra fazer mas também temos um
limite da vida e isso tem muita coisa
pra fazer e quer fazer muita coisa no
gps para tenter vezes e de s
não não dá isto é é muito importantes
nós conseguirmos é fazer o nosso saber
usar o que temos para chegar a algum
lado
no nosso centro disso diz aqui paixão
disse aqui várias coisas
mas pra mim é uma coisa aqui em todas as
apresentações que foram feitas
enfim este é um papel em branco que era
pra vocês construíram o vosso passou mas
há uma coisa que me muito gozo e eu pra
mim as coisas fazem-se com muita
determinação muita determinação legal